I'm with Kevin Prince and I'm going to
teach him something that you might not
know which is how to throw a bucket of
water at someone yeah you have the
bucket right um this is not if you want
to actually drench someone if you're
angry at them but this is how you throw
a bucket of water if you are on stage I
got taught this by a pantomime Dame
several years ago when I was compact hug
and the key thing is that what you do
normally did to drench someone is not
what you wanted you're on stage it's a
bigger audience watching you on YouTube
or in the theater and you want to go for
dramatic effect and you also don't wanna
suck through the costume so you fill it
too much then you're gonna have too much
for mentioning it but half of it too
little it's nothing a little bit so you
want to aim for the chin this is a key
block the water under the chin two
reasons number one here in the chest
it's gonna absolutely drench them which
means a dry out the costume
lots of young number two hit the chin
creates an enormous splash Young's
backwards give it a brilliant show of
the audience doesn't really get a person
away so you ready yep okay you ready yep
I'm teaching go to mixed is try try
again
one two three
that is very throw a bunch of water
[Laughter]
you